Liz comms 2016 keynote has wrapped but
the opening ceremony was absolutely
packed with announcements I'm Tony and
this is your loaded gamespot news update
first up overwatch we finally got to see
sombra in action as expected she's a
hacker with the tools to shut down enemy
abilities and health packs teleport and
unleash an EMP blast two new maps were
also revealed oasis and echo point
Antarctica finally overwatch will be
receiving in arcade mode with exclusive
maps and special game types like 1 V 1
and 3 VIII's sombra arcade mode and the
arcade exclusive Antarctica map hit the
public test realm next week with oasis
coming in December now on to starcraft
which is getting new co-op missions and
a new co-op commander the Terran captain
Alexey sukhov the new missions and
character will be available on November
22nd heroes of the storm is also getting
new characters two of them to be exact
Varian win is the game's first multi
class hero meaning you can become more
offensive or defensive as the game goes
on ending as a shielded warrior or a
vicious assassin he'll be available in
the public test realm next week while
the fiery ragnaros arrives in December
as for hearthstone card players will be
getting a new expansion later this year
mean streets of gadgets dan adds 132 new
cards to the game including new try
class cards that give your minions
health discover more cards in the deck
or cast custom spells and finally let's
talk about Diablo yes the necromancer
class is on the way and it'll be
available in 2017 on top of this a
special 20th anniversary patch hits the
public test realm next week this adds a
new dungeon containing the original four
bosses from Diablo 1 but with a twist
the graphics will be grainy like the
original release old-school music will
play and movement will be restricted to
eight directions it'll feel like 1996
again at least in this one particular
dungeon
blizzcon 2016 runs through Saturday
November fifth so keep checking back for
even more news we'll be posting all the
big stuff on gamespot but for all the
most important trailers and updates
you're already in the right place
you